[Music]
good afternoon everybody
Am I am I on I am great I want to
welcome you all to our annual State of
the Institute we started this a couple
years ago and much while it requires
some preparation I have to say I really
do look forward to it it's an
opportunity for me and the provost the
Chancellor and the executive vice
president and treasurer to just give you
an update on the current state of MIT
we've got I would say good news to
report the bottom line is good news to
report and somewhat turbulent time I
just want to comment on the photographs
you have been watching which I find
absolutely spectacular they are all
taken by MIT students the technique
yearbook staff photographers and I just
think they're absolutely fantastic
another example of the extraordinary
range of skills and talents of our of
our undergraduates so I cannot begin
without commenting that these are
unsettling times they're a little
uncertain and no doubt there is no one
in this audience who is not aware of the
major reorganizations of the financial
institutional landscape that is
unfolding in the markets even as we
speak no one can predict where we will
be at the end of the week never mind at
the end of the month or the year and I
just want to reflect that at a time like
this I would say even more so than in
normal times it's wonderful to be part
of a place like MIT the importance of
what we do is only more important as the
country and the world seek to solve the
most pressing problems we can help and
even in these times and especially so we
have to remember mi t--'s mission of
service and our leadership on so many
issues I'm acutely aware that leadership
is important in good times and in bad
and this is a critical time for MIT to
lead they continue to set the standards
research and education and also to set
the standards for how we do our work and
I want to call out some of the
characteristics of MIT that I've
certainly internalized over the last
four years we set the standards for I
would say characteristic dedication to
our work for hard work and for the
integrity about which we with which we
go about our work our mission is to lead
in service in education and research and
it's important that we call out those
rules particularly now now I am going to
be focusing on our many strengths and I
would say only a few of our many
strengths some of the sources of those
strengths I have to apologize for those
of you who are involved in important and
strength building parts of the Institute
that I just don't have a chance to touch
on today if I covered everything that
was exciting me about MIT we'd be here
all afternoon not only would you miss
lunch you'd miss the rest of the day so
I will only highlight a few that have
come to my attention but it doesn't mean
that those that I don't speak about are
any less important or any less exciting
I want to start with our finances which
is an area of understandable concern the
bottom line here again is that our
finances are in really terrific shape we
have done a huge amount of hard work
over the last two or three years to
build a new framework that better
harnesses all of our financial resources
and this work has happened in two
different parts and I will describe them
very briefly but it really is
readjusting how we work on our operating
finances and also coming up with a new
policy for how we use our endowment
first we have restructured our financial
framework to optimize the use of or the
balance between the use of our
expendable and our endowed funds this is
a project that we've called rebalancing
it has been very hard work
it has been led by the Provost Rafael
rife the executive vice president and
treasurer of Terry stone vice president
for finance Israel Ruiz and lots of
people in their offices and lots of all
of you it's required work by the
Department
Lab Center heads and AOS and you know I
don't know that we could count the
number of people who have contributed to
this I want to thank you for coming
together around an effort that has
positioned MIT to face the future far
more effectively than we have in the
past one of the products of this effort
over the last couple of years is that we
are operating from a balanced budget in
FY o nine this is the first balanced
budget that MIT has had in many years
now many people say well if we can
operate in a balanced budget year or an
on balance here why should we care and I
respond that we should care deeply about
this because a balanced budget means we
can focus on the future we don't have to
worry so much about what happened in the
past and worry about how we're going to
recover from the past for operating from
a balanced budget it provides us the
strongest possible platform to imagine
the future the second piece of this is
that we've adopted a new endowment
spending policy the details of which you
can find out if you need to by
contacting us but the basic message is
this new endowment spending policy
dampens the volatility it will smooth
the payout from the endowment and a
better balance is the purpose of the
endowment which is to support the
students and faculty the research and
education of today and also preserve the
value of the endowment for the future
generations of faculty and students
something we call intergenerational
neutrality we can't rob the future to
pay for today and we can't rob today to
pay for the future and getting that
balance right is really important the
reason why we've been so focused excuse
me on smoothing the payout from the
endowment is that the endowment now
provides about 20% of our operating
revenues for our budget that's a big
fraction and if you look at how our
operating expenses fall out over a third
of our operating costs are for people
salaries and benefits and MIT is an
organization that is first and foremost
about people those people are all of you
and we want to be sure that we can steer
a steady course and to do that we need a
reliable and smooth payout from the
endowment speaking of the end down
we reported some good news this week the
endowment returns for last year our 3.2
percent that's the returns on the
investment lots of the other
institutions that we watched very
closely have been announcing their
returns also and they tend to be in the
single digits
mostly clustering around the middle
single digits like ours there are a few
institutions several institutions that
have a reported negative returns this is
a cause for concern but I have great
confidence that our Investment Office
under the direction of our chief
investment officer Seth Alexander excuse
me is doing the best job they can and
certainly the returns this year speak to
that as we look forward I would say the
stratospheric rates of return of the
past are likely to be in the past for
quite a while and there are more
difficult times ahead but the work that
I have described both on our financial
framework and it and our diamond
spending policy position us in the
strongest possible way to get us through
even challenging times many of you have
asked me or one of us what our plans are
to deal with the financial turmoil and I
would say no one knows what's going to
happen we're monitoring the situation
very closely but for now there there's
every indication that we're going to be
able to stay the course with the budget
that we laid out for this year I think
in good times and in bad but I would say
particularly now our watchwords or
prudence and vigilance but I know that's
the way all of us operate anyway they're
particularly more important today so
just to sum up this part the changes in
our financial framework and our
endowment spending allow us to think
about all of our finances all of our
financial resources comprehensively and
fully integrated in MIT as decision
making and it really has happened we've
completed this work just in time to be
in a strong position to whether rocky
conditions that may lie ahead let me
talk a little bit about our continuing
campus improvements we have some new
facilities coming along most of us
encounter them as we walk around the
mess of construction the sidewalk is
closed here and you gotta cross the
street or there's some you know a new
mud puddle you got to walk through so I
thought it would be important for you
actually see some photographs of what
these constructions
are going to look like we have three
buildings coming along there's a Media
Lab extension for the School of
Architecture MIT Sloan also has a new
building and the building in the middle
is the new Koch Institute for
Integrative Cancer Research for the
Media Lab extension which is a project
with the School of Architecture and
planning and the MIT Sloan building we
have succeeded in a new approach to
financing these magnificent new
facilities we have already raised 70% of
the cost of these buildings at both of
them and we anticipate having raised 80%
by the time we open those buildings on
both of these buildings are going to
provide really new opportunities new
intellectual directions the Media Lab
extension will provide an environment
that's going to leak link research and
education in different forms of
communication and in human augmentation
a very exciting set of projects among
the groups that are going to be in this
extension are the program and
comparative Media Studies in the Center
for Advanced visual studies the Legatum
center for development and
entrepreneurship and the okawa Center
for future children the Sloan building
is really going to transform space for
the Sloan School and it's going to
enable the school to undertake 21st
century business education and research
which has been very difficult in the
spaces that they've been inhabiting this
21st century approach to business
education and research is increasingly
group based and it's increasingly
tailored to specific needs individual
needs we see that a lot in our executive
education programs and this building
will facilitate those kinds of
activities the Koch Institute for
Integrative Cancer Research is a
magnificent collaboration between the
School of Science and the School of
Engineering it will house about 25
faculty members about half from
engineering at about half from science
this group is coming together to really
change the frontier for cancer diagnosis
cancer treatment and cancer prevention
and the excitement of these scientists
and engineers working together is just
you know almost indescribable happily we
have had a
very accelerated start on fundraising
from our devoted and generous alumnus
David Koch David graduated from MIT with
a bachelor's degree in 62 and a master's
degree in 63 both in chemical
engineering David and his three brothers
are all cancer survivors
so his involvement in this project is
more than just I would say remote and
theoretical he is anxious to help us get
progress in this area as anxious as any
I would say one personal world worried
about David as any of you who have seen
him or met him know that he's very tall
he was a basketball player at MIT
actually a star basketball player he
still holds the record for most points
scored in a single game I would throw
that out to our students as a challenge
I'm sure you would take it in you know
exactly the right light if one of our
current students were to best his record
I would say I've given you a very quick
overview of these abilities buildings if
you're curious to learn more about these
building projects you can go on the
website just go to the home page and
then at the end of our homepage URL
slash facilities slash there are
beautiful descriptions and lots of
detail about all three of these on that
site if you go under the tab that says
in development and construction now
speaking of raising money which I have I
want to also report to you on the
extraordinary success of this past year
resource development and the Alumni
Association have had a banner year
there's been a huge increase in new
gifts and pledges and increase over a
preview and over last year of 27% but
it's the highest level for gifts and
pledges ever in the Institute's history
now while we often raise to talk about
the dollars raised in terms of dollars
the thing I watch really closely is
participation levels because I view
participation as a proxy for the
enthusiasm with which our alumni and our
donors what the enthusiasm they bring to
what we do at MIT the senior gift this
year is one example of that kind of
enthusiasm when I arrived four years ago
the first class that graduated when I
was here at MIT the class parties the
senior gift participation was 27%
I actually believe that our seniors were
more grateful for their MIT experience
and that 27% indicated and I challenged
the Alumni Association to work with the
students to see if we could do better
this year's participation is sixty four
point four percent is an institute
record and it really does emphasize how
our students appreciate the environment
that we've provided for them it's a way
for our students to say thank you and
the people is saying thank you to is all
of you because all of you have been
critical in providing our students with
absolutely the very best education and
learning environment I believe anywhere
in the world we will launch our campaign
for students which I hope you've all
heard about on Friday I'm going to come
back to that in just a minute
speaking of students they are our most
rich source of new ideas and new
enthusiasm we admitted this fall a new
group of undergraduate and graduate
students that are extraordinary
extraordinary in their scholarship and
their talents their skills in the
classroom and outside of the classroom I
would say undergraduate admissions this
year was a bit challenging a bit
challenging because there were two
things that changed in the environment
the first was that some of our peer
schools Harvard Princeton and the
University of Virginia abandoned their
early admissions programs this made it
very hard for us to predict in any way
what the outcome of our admissions was
going to be with that variable thrown
into the mix and there were new very
aggressive financial aid practices
announced by Harvard Yale and Stanford
and they accompanied Princeton in very
aggressive financial aid the bottom line
on this year's admissions is that we did
very well and this is thanks again to
the amazing group of people who work in
our admissions office and our financial
aid office under the brilliant
leadership of stew Chanel and Betsy
Hicks this year we had the highest
number of applications in the
Institute's history it is the third year
in a row that we have seen eight percent
or greater increases in application
number we had almost 30
thousand four hundred young people
applying for admission to be an
undergraduate here at MIT
this produced the lowers lowest ever
admit rate just less than twelve percent
of the students who applied were
admitted the yield despite these new
variables was very high at sixty six
percent the third highest in our history
and the students as I said are brilliant
ninety-one percent of our freshman
graduated in the top five percent of
their high school classes forty percent
with the valedictorians in their high
school classes twenty four percent of
what we call academic stars that means
they've distinguished themselves in some
kind of competition of their way they
are brilliant and a delight to have join
us on campus one of the things that I
always want to keep in mind and I think
all of us should keep in mind is mi
t--'s policies and practices for
admissions
you know we view we review the
applications for admission in a way that
is completely need-blind the admissions
office determines who should who should
to be admitted and who not to MIT
without any regard to a student or a
student's family to pay for an MIT
education the financial aid that we
provide is provided entirely need-based
so a student doesn't get financial aid
because they're more meritorious in some
way than some other not because they're
a good football player or a particularly
phenomenal mathematician even it's all
need-based and then we're committed to
meeting the full need of all of our
admitted students this means at the end
of the day that 60% of our
undergraduates receive financial aid
from MIT and 90% of our students receive
financial aid from any number of sources
including MIT we have a group of
students that we believe can make the
best use of our intellectual resources
and we provide the financial resources
to allow them to come here we're
continuing our important progress to
make MIT increasingly more affordable
this year for the first time for all of
our students who come from families with
annual incomes of 75,000 dollars a year
and below these students are attending
without any need to take a loan to pay
for tuition
what that means is that among the
students who receive financial aid among
the sixty percent of students are
receive financial aid the average
tuition for that group of students is
just about eight thousand dollars a year
which is a very pronounced reduction
from our standard which is now well over
thirty five thousand dollars a year I
have to remind you that even at full
tuition the tuition does not cover even
half the costs of an MIT education so
through all the work that we do all the
financial work that we do we're really
providing an enormous Lee important
subsidy for education we remain
committed to making MIT possible for all
of those who can make the best use of
our community make the best use of our
faculty our staff the other students are
phenomenal labs and other resources the
admissions landscape still has a lot of
unknowns this year and we're going to be
monitoring the conditions and adapt as
required I have to share with you one
story about a student as many of you
know last January we got a call from the
Senate Finance Committee from senators
Baucus and Grassley asking us to
basically account for how we use our
endowment in support of education it was
I would say not the most pleasant of
experiences this call went out to I
think that the schools with the the 100
top endowments in the country so a lot
of schools were scrambling to answer
pages and pages of questions from the
Senate Finance Committee I received a
copy of a letter that was sent to the
Senators and I want to read you from
this it was a letter from a father of an
MIT student who's from South Dakota who
lives in South Dakota and the letter
begins by describing that he like many
people in that part of the country is a
family comes from a family of modest
means and when his son came home from
school one day and said that his
ambition was to come to MIT his father
just said good luck son
we can't afford it so let me read to you
from the letter that this father sent
two senators Baucus and Grassley the
financial assistance we have received
from MIT has been incredible and I don't
use that word lightly in fact the best
offer we got from a state supported
school in South Dakota would have cost
us more
out of pocket that MIT does furthermore
and I acknowledge the risk of perceived
elitism here MIT is truly a world-class
University one of a very few that truly
have earned that distinction within the
United States what serious student would
not want to attend such an institution
students who earn admission to MIT and
the key word there is earn show academic
promise combined with the willingness to
work for their knowledge and the
students I have met impressed me with
their capabilities beyond standard
academics they are truly leaders in
training in the sciences mathematics
engineering and other high demand areas
these are the young men and women who in
the next 20 to 30 years will be called
on to maintain this nation's leading
rule leading role in the technological
world it is an incredible honor for my
son to be included in this group and
that honor would not be possible if not
for mi t--'s financial assistance for
its students I couldn't have said it
better let me move on to make a few
comments about teaching and research
it's what we do here it's what inspires
us it is our mission and of course our
faculty sit at the very center of our
research and education enterprise it's
hard to describe just how brilliant and
productive our faculty are one way is to
just pay attention to the awards they
receive it seems to me that hardly a
week goes by when someone hasn't
received some astonishing award and in
fact just in the last week it was
announced that two of our faculty
received MacArthur Genius Awards and
three received NIH pioneer awards the
MacArthur awards our two are out of a
total of 25 that were awarded across the
world and as I said we know these has
the MacArthur Genius award the Pioneer
Awards there's a new award from NIH the
three that MIT faculty received are out
of 16 that were awarded across the
country and these awards these grants go
in recognition of exceptional creativity
in the spring several of our faculty
five new faculty received how
Hughes Medical Institute investigator
Awards HHMI Awards this is about among
the highest recognitions of achievement
in science and also now in engineering
with those five new HHMI investigators
it brings the total at MIT to 19 which
is more than any other institution in
the country and I would say while all
this is wonderful
one of the hm-hm I investigator Awards
calls out what really sits at the center
of what we do at MIT and it's the
integration of research and education
professor of chemistry Cathy Brennan is
one of our new HHMI investigators but
she previously had been recognized as an
HHMI professor the HHMI professorships
go to individuals who have particularly
distinguished themselves in teaching and
have shown a passion for innovative ways
of conveying their subject in the
classroom professor Drennan is the only
person in the history of HHMI to receive
both in each of each and my professor
and investigator award and I would say
nothing could speak more deeply about
MIT s commitment to the integration of
teaching and research there was yet
another set of honors for Institute
professor Bob Langer including the
Millennium technology a prize which is
given for technology innovation let me
talk a bit about our strengths and
service to the world this is part of our
mission the world is hungry for the kind
of solutions that MIT provides the
Institute why'd MIT the MIT Energy
Initiative which is Institute wide is
just one example Ernie Moniz has been
doing a terrific job as director and Bob
Armstrong as Deputy Director every week
there is a new breakthrough that I read
about in the newspapers and they come
from every one of our five schools on
campus the Energy Initiative is taking
form in the task force on campus
sustainability Terry stone will be
talking about that in her comments in
just a minute and one of the great
achievements this year is that there's
growing awareness of mi t--'s
contributions outside of campus campus
The Economist in their June 21st issue
had an
entire section devoted to energy and I
would say almost every page mentioned
something that came out of MIT not
branded as such but MIT was all over
this particular issue MIT continues to
have an important voice in DC
particularly around energy there were
MIT faculty witnesses on 23
congressional hearings on energy over
the last year and a half we have been
very actively informing both
presidential campaigns doesn't make any
difference who's president who ever I
mean in terms of what has to be done
what has to be done is we have to build
the base for innovation through research
and education in the United States and
we have been giving material to both
campaigns in this particular vein so as
I travel around the country in the world
I'm struck over and over by how much the
world looks to and trusts MIT trust us
for our expertise for our technology
breakthroughs and importantly for our
role as an honest broker on really
complicated issues we're continuing to
build academic strengths at MIT
following on from the Energy Initiative
the Provost announced last week a new
environmental Research Council which
will extend the energy initiatives work
into broader issues in the environment
they'll speak to that later and our
school deans have been working in new
ways both within their schools and
across the schools and have brought a
really new level of excitement to MIT
and the Provost will also talk a little
bit more about that diversity continues
to be an important focus here at MIT
there is no question that we need the
contributions of all who want to
participate in a science and technology
centered enterprise we can't waive leave
out the women we can't leave out the
minorities who want to be part of this
work we need all the strength we can get
you know at MIT we don't actually need
to talk about excellence of the highest
caliber as we admit students so as we
bring in faculty as we hire staff it
just goes without staying and we would
hope that at some point a diversity goal
would be similarly internalized there's
lots of important work going on I can't
list all of the activity
they're fewer on the screen last year
was our first with our new associate
provost for faculty equity Institute
Provost Barbara Liskov serving mainly
issues around women and professor Wesley
Harris serving is in issues
predominantly around minorities but the
two of them were working very closely
together and with our faculty I want to
call out one upcoming event it's the
diversity Leadership Congress that will
be held November 18th the purpose of the
conference's congress is really to
spread the mantle of leadership more
broadly through the institute we will
gather together about 300 of the
academic administrative and student
leaders their role is to participate in
the conversation of the congress and
then to bring what they learn to the
congress back to the people they work
with and talk to the goal is to widen
and strengthen leadership for this key
issue and the congress is going to
provide an opportunity to find out from
others who have been key protagonists he
helpers in diversity issues at other
places to find out from them what's
worked and what hasn't worked and then
for all of us to work together to build
approaches that are truly worthy of MIT
what's important for everyone to
understand about the diversity
leadership congress it is a conversation
and a planning session it's an
opportunity to together understand
what's possible and how we can
accelerate our progress let me close by
returning to our students and how we're
building strength for them and from
through that through our students
building strength through the world I
want to start with a short video clip
from some of the materials that we've
assembled for the campaign for students
let's watch the video
I was interested in what drives personal
happiness how does working on
challenging technical problems propel a
person and motivate a person and make
them wildly happy to be alive what I've
learned at MIT we can listen and learn
as much as possible from other people in
their experiences doing things that are
not selfish or self-centered in nature
but doing things that are looking to the
benefit and service of all humanity
I really like biology because there's a
good chance that you'll be helping
people if not in your lifetime the
research will be helping people sometime
in the future you can see where it's
going
ultimately I want to be able to help any
sort of individual faction suffers from
the sort of behavioral disorders because
ultimately they are absolutely
devastating I want to help people
building a device that's gonna save
lives like I never imagined that I'd be
doing that the dedication of our excited
engineering work as that kind of direct
benefit that's perfect
I grew up to love cycling because it
epitomizes everything else in my life
it's this constant struggle against
yourself to be the best person that you
can be how do we not just limit the bad
things how to really create true value
wealth happiness joy peace what does it
take what do you do if you want the
world to be awesome you know how do you
spark that how do you make that happen
[Music]
our students I find this for so many
times I can't tell you I find it
enormously enormously moving it's easy
to get excited if you want to see more
of these video clips you can go on the
web at the human factor mit.edu as i
said the campaign for students will have
a public launch on Friday this is a
designed as a birthday present for the
Institute's a hundred and fiftieth
birthday in 2011 we've already raised
more than 55 percent of our goal to
raise 500 million dollars Chancellor
Phil clay is the Institute leader of the
campaign and he'll say more about it in
just a few minutes I want to talk about
the spirit of this campaign the spirit
really is about our leadership in good
times and bad it's about building a
strong foundation that the future
requires it's about building fundamental
growth in the United States fundamental
growth stems from innovation and driving
the innovation economy that has so
benefited this country requires sound
policies and absolute commitment to
education and research this campaign the
campaign for students and indeed
everything we do at MIT is about
accelerating these important advances by
unleashing the unlimited potential of
the human factor so MIT has strengths in
many areas and I want to close with just
one last piece of evidence as if you
needed any more I'm going to read from a
letter from a grateful scholarship
student one of the 60% to the donors of
the scholarship fund this was a fund
that was given to us by dick and Jenny
Simmons who are among our most generous
supporters you conceive him them here
with their students
their generosity you can see all over
campus and what they've done in the past
but currently it's in evidence in the
renovation of Vassar Street West I mean
what spectacularly committed and devoted
donors we have to help us repair a road
that's really dedication
anyway case the letter from the student
begins with an account of his freshman
year which included starting a business
with four other students a trip to
Mongolia to study the emerging coal
mining industry and to work with One
Laptop Per child and then he closes with
the description of a meeting with his
friends excuse me after final exams
present excuse me were three Iranians
two Indians a Pakistani three Americans
including myself a Haitian and a Chinese
one of the Iranians wrote some of the
code for the robotic spacecraft that
recently landed on Mars the Haitian won
last year's 200k business competition
for his team's development of a low cost
high efficiency water purification
purification system for use in
developing countries the Chinese fellow
runs a small but rapidly growing venture
capital firm focused on student start-up
companies in China and the u.s. the
Pakistani is one of the top theoretical
physics majors at MIT attending on a
full scholarship looking around that
gathering it was clear to me that the
diversity of the attending group was
rivaled only by the motivation and
innovative capacity of its members a
circumstance which I think fairly well
sums up MIT in general what can I add
that's why we're all here and what keeps
us working so hard to make this the best
possible place for education research
their challenge I challenge in times
ahead to be sure but we will work
together to face them to adapt as
conditions require so that we can
continue our important service to the
nation in the world now we're going to
hear from the provost the Chancellor and
the EVP and treasurer treasurer and then
I hope we'll have time to take questions
next up is the Provost Rafael rifle
II
good morning Allison I think I need some
help good morning
that worked my remarks today contain a
very simple message and one that I will
summarize for you right away
MIT is in terrific shape in my opinion
this period of time more than any other
in MIT s history belongs to MIT I will
explain now why I'm so confident of this
statement what defines a great
University today in addition to
educating outstanding students a great
university creates knowledge in the most
important scientific challenges of the
day apply this knowledge to solve the
most important problems and enables the
transfer of these solutions to the
commercial sector what are the most
important scientific challenges of today
the answer is relatively obvious energy
environment poverty health cancer
technology design innovation finances
and the list goes on why is MIT in
terrific shape
because in all these areas MIT is
creating an ology applying it to solve
important problems and transferring
solutions to the commercial sector in
short MIT faculty staff and students are
leading in pioneering in all these
critical areas as a result smart
individuals are attracted to MIT to be
part of a community that wants to make a
difference a unique feature of the MIT
community is the way it goes
working on important problems MIP
operates as a single community where for
example researchers from one department
collaborate with scholars from other
departments or schools in C cell for
instance computer scientists collaborate
with engineers and with math researchers
in C MSC chemists physicists material
scientists and engineers collaborate
with each other working in areas that
matter as a single community and
creating new knowledge disciplines and
curricula have been the hallmark of MIT
today this way of doing things is
sometimes referred to as
interdisciplinary and many academic
institutions are trying to figure out
how to do this successfully mit has been
doing it for over 60 years starting with
the creation of RLE a research lab of
electronics in 1946 since then our
relief physicists and engineers have
carried out pioneering interdisciplinary
research our model of educational
research our focus on science and
engineering in our hands-on practical
approach to solving the world's most
important problems have never been more
relevant or more important this is why I
can state with confidence that this
period of time belongs to MIT let me now
give you some more specifics at MIT each
of our five schools is a leader in what
they do and each school benefits from
the presence of the other four leading
schools in addition our schools benefit
from MIT s unique science and in
technology focus our collective goal is
to continue to be the institution that
attracts the best and the brightest that
is why since early this year our five
schools have been engaging on what we
are referring to us a visioning exercise
it
school is examining what they do and
defining their vision as an MIT school
and as a leading school in academia
there is not enough time for me to share
with you all that the deans are doing
thinking and planning but I will try to
give you just a few samples researchers
in the School of Engineering are
figuring out how to build electronic
gadgets such as cell phones and PDAs
that do not need batteries their goal is
to develop electronics that can be
powered completely using scavenged
energy for example using vibrations or
body heat to power electronic devices
the research involves developing micro
generators as well as electronics that
consume minimal amounts of energy this
group is working on an energy processor
that can convert vibration energy to
electric energy this research will
enable a number of self-powered micro
systems such as implantable medical
devices that can be powered indefinitely
if you want to know more about this work
check the website of the Microsystems
technology laboratories in the school of
science some of the most exciting
advances involve the convergence of the
life sciences with the physical sciences
and engineering to understand diagnose
and treat diseases for example in cancer
research rapid sequencing at the Broad
Institute has identified new genes and
the Koch Institute is bringing together
life scientists who study the biology of
cancer with engineers who are finding
new techniques for detection and
treatment in addition neuroscientist
cognitive scientists and engineers are
doing similar breakthrough research in
brain disorders such as autism and
Alzheimer's
Shaz is planning an exciting Global
Studies program for undergraduates the
program would offer undergraduate the
opportunity to study the subject of
their major
usually science or engineering
simultaneously with a deep study of a
particular region of the world these
global studies scholars would work
closely with their advisors and with
faculty from all five schools who are
interested in the same region students
would study language as well as the
literature and social sciences of their
chosen regions this academic work would
supplemented will be supplemented with
co-curricular activities such as misti
internships high ropes and other
international programs MIT Sloan just
launched a master of Finance program
recent events in Wall Street suggest
that the world's financial system needs
the kind of business leaders that MIT
uniquely develops with deep knowledge of
uncertain complex systems in addition
faculty members at MIT Sloan are
conducting research on sustainable
economic development this includes an
understanding of the technological
economic and social dimensions of energy
capacity greenhouse gases criminal
factoring and sustainable human capital
finally researchers in the School of
Architecture and planning have
traditionally focused their attention on
the needs of the disadvantaged an
example of this is the multimedia
large-scale projection called veterans
vehicle project that gives voice to
veterans who struggle with homelessness
more recently researchers at the Media
Lab initiated a center for human
augmentation the goal is to develop new
technologies that enhance and extend
human capabilities and overcome human
disabilities a specific example is the
powered ankle foot prosthesis that is
transforming the lives of leg amputees
in addition to this very brief academic
nugget from our schools all of them are
strongly committed to increase the
diversity of our faculty staff and
students a trust you agree with me that
M IDs
many programs are in great shape yet I'm
sure some of you are asking yourselves
how are we going to be able to continue
to implement our goals in the present
financial climate let me answer with the
following as president Hockfield said in
her remarks the general institute budget
what we call as a ji b for this fiscal
year is balanced with no deficit it is
the first time as president Hockfield
said in many years that MIT enjoys a
balanced g ib this has been the result
of the hard work of many dedicated staff
and faculty leaders at MIT it is a
remarkable feat and our major
accomplishments and I expect the
Institute to benefit from this position
for years to come
a balanced budget allows us to take the
time to understand any possible impact
the financial markets may have on MIT us
right now it is too early to tell it is
important to state at this time however
that MIT is most important asset is the
people of MIT and mi t--'s most
important commitment is to its people
before I conclude I would like to add a
couple of recent faculty activities it
is extremely important to bring our
faculty together to address our most
complex challenges president Hockfield
already mentioned the Environmental
Research Council let me mention three
other recent faculty committees that
have been convened earlier this month I
announced the creation of an MIT global
Council chaired by Professor Richard
Samuels and professor D cube the
formation of this council is a
recognition that we are all interlinked
in a global marketplace and that we need
to educate our students to compete and
succeed in this global environment the
council is charged with developing a
long-range plan for the creation of an
undergraduate educational program such
as the Global Studies Program I
mentioned earlier two additional ad hoc
faculty committees were created
them as a result this as a result of the
increased complexity of a research
enterprise and our tech transfer
activities one of the committees is
focusing on managing potential conflicts
of interest in research the chair of
this committee is instead of professor
sheila widnall the primary focus
includes a review of activities that
could give rise to conflicts of interest
an examination of our existing policies
and procedures and a review of what we
do today to monitor possible conflicts
of interest the committee is expected to
recommend possible changes to our
policies and procedures the other
committee is focusing on MIT technology
transfer for the 21st century the chair
of this committee is Professor Charlie
Cooney the primary focus of this
committee includes exploring ways to
accelerate technology transfer and
review principles that govern our
industrial engagements whether it is
launching a new academic program or
making a new discovery or launching a
new initiative or transferring
technology that will revolutionize an
industry the success of each of this
effort the pains in great measure in the
people in this room as president hopeful
know that in her remarks the only
limiting factor in what we can achieve
together is the human factor MIT is
about the people of MIT I started
telling you that this time period
belongs to MIT I explained that this is
so because of the work we do and the way
we do it but MIT success is primarily
due to the people of MIT I've had the
opportunity to work directly with many
of you I'm proud of working with you and
I'm proud of what all of us have
accomplished together let's remind
ourselves of the tremendous legacy on
our collective shoulders the legacy of
working at one of the best
education and research institutions in
the land let's work together to make the
following statement of reality MIT is
best years are yet to come thank you
No
My dear colleague Chancellor Phil clay
good morning there's still some morning
left I want to first of all say how
pleased I am to report on the state of
the Institute as regards education in
student life I share Raphael's view and
Susan's view that we are in very good
shape and this is very encouraging as we
moved into a difficult economic period
as well as a very hopeful exercise
without alumni and friends and raising
support for the Institute our mission is
to provide the resources and support to
students in their journeys of discovery
and intellectual and personal
development and in campus life we seek
to ignite creativity and leadership and
service because these are the activities
on campus that will allow our young
people to go out with great confidence
not false confidence but grounded
confidence in what they know and in what
they can contribute against the goal we
have we've come a long way in the last
few years the MIT of today is better
than the MIT that many of us attended as
alumni and we have made steady progress
we recognize the challenges that remain
we are positioned to perform against our
mission and to perform well I'm positive
that we were on the right track
particularly noting today that we have
made a number of efforts over the period
of the last ten years that is since the
task force on student life issues its
report in 1998 to improve student life
faculty staff and students have made
many contributions over this decade to
achieve the goals set forth in that
report each year we made progress and
this past year has been no exception we
also note that the faculty task force on
the education Commons continues to have
insight about how we advance and improve
our educational offerings some of the
work
for implementing the recommendations of
that task force have already been taken
and faculty continues to wrestle with
other aspects and we hope that wrestling
will come to an end this year the class
of 2012 by every measure grades test
scores diversity accomplishments that
they bring with them to this campus and
the arts leadership and public service
is the best ever and is without peer in
talent or promise the number of
applications as president Hockfield
identified in her report
all of them all of these indicators are
positive as well but I want to report
based on conversations with students and
families that the students have come
here with a great deal of enthusiasm and
continue to have it not just those who
came here in September but those who are
proceeding through their undergraduate
and graduate careers as well now you
will recall last spring that there was
some worry that the more generous aid
offered by some of our peers would have
an adverse effect on our enrollment
goals and on our diversity economic and
otherwise
now we expanded our support almost 10%
and did a number of things that were
very creative so that our final
enrollment this year is as strong as it
has ever been now we are mindful as we
will discuss in a moment
that we will continue to have challenges
and that we will work very hard to meet
those challenges we learned in the
process that we are on the right track
but we also learn that each year there
are new challenges and we will wait for
what the challenges are this year for
enrolling our next class you will also
note that in the recent rankings MIT and
many of its departments and schools
continued in their usual leadership
status it's true for MIT as a whole and
as Raphael indicated it's true for
departments and all five of our schools
we provide an increasingly rich
environment for students the physical
environment the academic environment and
the community environment for life and
learning and I want to pay particular
attention to the physical improvements
that have been made on the campus in
recent years both major capital projects
as well as the renovation of new
buildings and other parts of our
infrastructure all of these enhancements
have helped as well
now we opened about six weeks ago new
Ashdown W 35 and it's a wonderful new
facility but more importantly it is the
linchpin in a new community the
northwest community where there are now
more than 1500 graduate students who
call the area home several thousand of
you showed up there three weeks ago for
a community picnic demonstrating that
the distance there is not far and
developments in the opening of the new
dorm point to its emergence as a real
community we had no master plan I must
admit for this graduate campus as it has
turned out to be our decade of muddling
through has yielded a wonderful space
where students have embraced and are
committed to making it their own
but muddling through is not a sufficient
strategy and we're working very hard as
we renovate the W one or the Oh ash town
building to enhance the Western campus
so that it is transformative in powerful
ways for student campus life whether its
dining or in academic activities that
bridge the east and west side of the
campus we are working very hard and a
group of students are working very hard
to ensure that w1 joins us in two years
as a strong new linchpin on the western
part of the campus by 2007 it became
clear that we knew we had to do some new
things to secure our standing as a
leading University
we saw the evolving shape of our own
ambitions and the environment in higher
education and we saw that they require
that we needed more resources for
financial aid for our students and to
support our academic and Student Life
initiatives so I want to say a little
bit about what we have in mind and the
justification for the campaign that will
become public this Friday we are blessed
that most of the requirement required
resources for financial aid file
undergraduates has been secured by the
generous gift of alumni and Friends over
the years this gives us great assurance
in this difficult economic times but I
must also say that there is a part of
our commitment which is not secured and
one aspect of the campaign is to
generate the funds that will secure the
final portion of our undergraduate
financial commitment which is a deep
commitment to making sure that no
student who belongs at MIT and is
admitted will be without the resources
required to meet our costs and to meet
their life needs we also have a similar
need with respect to graduate students
the competition for graduate students is
as keen as the competition for talent of
18 year olds and every department faces
it and that the ways that departments
face this challenge will vary a bit by
school but a second piece of our
campaign aims to raise fellowships
support to make sure that each
department is in a position to compete
for the talent which will make sure that
our faculty will have the research
partners that they will need to continue
the great research work that we're doing
graduate students are a key part of our
research enterprise and there is no more
urgent task than to raise the funds
needed to make sure every department is
able to compete for talent a third part
of our campaign has to do with
generating support for the academic
and infrastructure that we all require
whether we're students or faculty and
the list of needs in this area is a very
long list we have buildings that need to
be renovated we have made a commitment
to provide more project-based learning
or international opportunities for our
students
all of these are new commitments we have
made that need the support of our
friends and finally students are here
for four years and they are here for
four very important years in their lives
and while there are some of us who used
to believe that student life was an
afterthought I didn't believe that very
long but some do for even our graduate
students need student life we do have
the opportunity to trends provide
transformative opportunities for our
students so that they not only
understand the analytical aspects of the
futures that they will face but they
also become personally prepared and
confident and going out into the world
and exercising their passions so student
life is an important part whether we are
trying to make sure that our athletes
athletes are sufficiently coached and
equipped or providing support for the
more than 300 student organizations or
making sure that their staff who will
help students as they take advantage of
the opportunities we want for all of
these to have the resources for student
life now over the last year I've had the
pleasure with many of my colleagues to
go around the country and make the case
for the campaign for students and I've
been very heartened by the response and
when the news comes out about that
response on Friday I think you will be
impressed as well but it is a wonderful
experience to go out and tell the MIT
story about students student life
educational opportunities and about the
accomplishments of our students there is
a longer version of the human factor
video which I would encourage you to see
and it has been my pleasure over the
last twelve months to have many of those
students and other students with us on
those 19 visits around the country to
make the case to our alumni and I can
assure you that their presentations to
alumni were very helpful in making the
progress we've made over the last year I
want to say two things in closing first
we are in some challenging economic
times we do not know the dimensions of
this challenge not its depth not its
breadth now nor do we know the duration
of these difficulties but I want to
emphasize that our commitment to support
students through this difficult time is
as strong as it could possibly be and
will be as deeply implemented as we have
in the past and finally I want to say
that we want to thank members of this
community because we know that all of
the progress we've made in recent years
could not have come without the effort
of many people in this campus on this
campus from custodians and physicians to
technical instructors and encounter and
accountants we have greatly improved the
infrastructure to support our students
and they appreciate it and I can assure
you of that from survey materials that
we keep track of and I think we are in a
great position to build on this for the
years to come thank you very much and I
give you Terry stop
well I suspect you would agree with me
just sitting through listening to what
we're doing here at MIT is an incredibly
inspiring story and I think you know
that we've kind of developed a way of
trying to capture what many of you here
in this room are involved in who work in
the non academic side of MIT which is we
have sort of coined the motto that we
are making an effort to provide services
that are worthy of MIT and we know that
MIT is at the very very top of the world
in terms of science and engineering
teaching and research and what we want
to do what we aspire to do is to attain
a sustained level of service for the
Institute that's worthy of it and I know
many of you in this room are involved in
doing that many of you who are on the
academic side are involved in
encouraging and giving us feedback so
that we can do that and I think we all
feel as if we really got some terrific
momentum in really all the areas what I
want to do is not talk about that
specifically but just spend a few
minutes on one particular initiative
that involves people all across campus
and collaboration from all the far
reaches of the Institute and that is the
campus Energy Initiative and just give
you a little bit of a summary of some of
the things that have been happening some
of the directions that we're going in
and of course my secret agenda here is
to get all of you and many of you
already are very involved and committed
to this because it only works if we're
all working on it so how have we gone
about the the campus Energy Initiative
there is a task force the which leads
this effort and I co-chair that with
Professor Leon Glicksman from the school
of architecture and we have
representatives on that task force from
every one of the schools from a
professor from each of the schools we
have graduate students we have
undergraduate students we have people
from the staff
and it's been just an incredibly
collaborative effort and an ingenious
effort to come up with strategies to
have an effect on how the campus is
using energy this place has been very
focused on this way before the last
couple of years when energy has been
come so much of a headline topic and
there have been things going on here
recycling green procurement sustainable
design commuting options that have been
speaking to this for some time indeed if
you go back in history you know we were
a leader in putting in a cogeneration
plant which many of our peers are now
making happen on their campus so this
has been a focus for a long long time
but there's a new focus now it's very
much across campus collaboration and as
a lot of education going on the
principles that we've adopted are that
it will be a comprehensive approach so
the utilities the transportation aspects
computing sustainable design education
and very clear understanding that it's
not just the engineering solutions which
are critical but it's also the
behavioral solutions because much of the
difference is going to happen because we
have behavioral changes in how we all
use energy on the campus it's extremely
inclusive we've got students decos
faculty and staff multidisciplinary
collaborative problem-solving it's a
very impressive effort our peers who ask
us about this are impressed with how
active and how much initiative is being
taken in facilities for to team up with
students to team up with with faculty to
come up with solutions that are going to
make sense for us and it's also very
disciplined
we have really insisted that you can't
make progress on these things if there's
no economic underpinnings to them and so
with the help of our colleagues from
around the Institute we've got a really
good return on investment approach to
this and we hope that in all of this
we're going to be able to model good
practices
that will have an influence and be
useful to individuals and other campuses
and other big organizations so those are
the principles comprehensive inclusive
and disciplined this is just a graphic
that Sabri states what I just said you
can see in the three balls on the on the
one side of the chart academic eunuch
student engagement administrative
departments and how they overlap there's
a organization chart there about the
Energy Initiative which of course is the
overriding group that leads energy on
energy issues here on campus with the
Energy Council and then there's a
research arm for that there's the
education task force and the campus
energy task force which we have early on
we called it the walk the talk task
force and there's a lot of interaction
among all of these boxes and you can see
the arrows they are kind of going back
and forth between the education piece
and the campus task force but I would
say the research speech is also very
important because we've had really
hugely great participation from our
academic experts helping us to come up
with ideas so here's a few things that
have been I think kind of typical
projects this is a steam trap
demonstration project so steam traps are
these little devices on the top of
radiators that regulate the steam and
what you can see there is a picture of
the two East Campus dorms the so-called
parallel dorms and a typical MIT fashion
what was decided was that we would fix
the steam traps on one and not fix the
steam traps on the other and see if
there was any impact so what you can see
at the top is the dorm that did not have
the steam traps fixed and that's how
much energy it used how much steam it
used all throughout from January to
February in the demonstration year and
then the black line on the bottom shows
you what happened after we fix the steam
traps which is we used much less steam
and importantly we had a variable amount
of steam that was used
and if you kind of track that against
the little red line that's there that's
the temperature so we use more steam
when the temperature was low and we use
less steam when the temperature was high
so with that as proof we've gotten this
steam trap replacement onto half the
academic buildings this has been a three
hundred sixty thousand dollar investment
and we've got a one-year payback on that
so we're just you know thrilled with
that kind of that kind of clarity and
discipline and proof and then action
this is another one which is ongoing
this is the chemical fume hood use if
you were to say to use a term where are
the big energy hogs on campus you know
our research buildings and particularly
our fume hoods
of which we have a thousand on campus
are the source of an awful lot of the
energy need on campus so what can we do
about that we're not we want to pursue
our research and do it at the very
highest level but are we doing it with
the greatest efficiency so the chemistry
department was a great partner for the
walk the talk group on this and agreed
to make some experiments in the
chemistry building and you can see on
this two levels of activity what we were
able to do the sash Heights which is the
sash being the device that you pull up
and down and and that closes the the
face of the fume hood if you leave it up
it's going to keep sucking air and
sucking energy and if you lower it down
when you're not using it then it will do
less of that so you can see we had about
a 25% improvement in the sash height
position during the trial period and
we've gotten great focus from the
chemistry department on this you can see
on the right we have been able to meter
the fume hoods and then we can give a
little report to the principal
investigator so that they can see what
the best person what the best
investigative team in their area was
able to do and what the worst those are
the sort of red and green boundaries
and then where they are how they can
stack up in terms of their performance
on this dimension compared to their
colleagues so there's nothing like
visibility and measuring and perhaps
indeed peer pressure to help on some of
these things so we're hoping with the
help of many of you in this room and
with the help of Environmental Health
and Safety who I think is a trusted
partner throughout the the Institute to
really get this word out to some of our
other very intensively energy utilizing
units here on campus importantly when
you're building a building you have to
think about energy and that's when you
can kind of set the path for for many of
the energy usage of the future and the
Koch Institute the Cancer Center which
is currently coming out of the ground
was a really nice example where our
professors from the Building
Technologies group were able to interact
with our engineering team and with the
architectural team that was working on
the building and focus on this issue of
the fume hoods and the HVAC systems
because the heating and air-conditioning
systems are really where an awful lot of
difference will get made in this and so
they're able to get in early on and
figured out that they could use energy
recovering heat pipes to reduce the
energy cost and we figure that's going
to be about four hundred fifty thousand
dollars a year of energy savings over
what we would have done if we hadn't
focused on it with the help of our
colleagues and building technology
upsizing the dot worked to reduce flow
losses and fan energy we figure that'll
save us
something over a hundred thousand
dollars a year and then importantly I
think this is this is something where we
think we really make a difference not
only for ourselves but also for the
disciplines around the world
we got the Environmental Health and
Safety folks the engineering folks the
building technology folks and other
outside experts to really focus on
whether our standards for face velocity
were needed because we do have standards
for these
we build buildings and the question is
where we overly conservative we always
obviously have to have safety as our
first objective and we know that safety
is particularly important because we
don't necessarily have very highly
trained at or scientists working in some
of these research labs we have people
who are learning about that as students
so we've got to be particularly
conservative in the way we do it but
with the conversations that went on and
with the with the work that was done we
were able to reduce the standard by 20
percent and still have complete
confidence that we've got the right
condo standard for safety so these are
things that really will change patterns
over the longer term in a certain way
standards for new buildings is the easy
part we have an enormous amount of
campus that is has 100-year histories to
it it has with its what they call in the
architectural world the built
environment our built environment as you
know has a lot that needs to happen for
it to be really energy-efficient and so
what we were able to do was to have a
project between the S lab at the Sloan
School the sustainability lab and some
of the teams in the walk the talk task
force including a lot of people from
facilities and some students work
together to come up with a methodology
for projects that that facilities came
up with here some kinds of things we can
imagine doing that would help with the
energy usage in our existing buildings
and then how would we think about the
economic impact of those the cost
benefit of doing them and so that one of
the benefits of course is that you save
energy but the saving of energy is also
connected to the economic savings and
the economic cost of getting there so
they developed what they called the
carbon mitigation matrix in this s lab
project and we're able to do their
return on investment analysis for a
whole portfolio of projects that
facilities was able to come up with and
then to rank order them and we
I decided to go from that things that
would have less than a three year
payback to see if we couldn't just start
to get some traction and also if we got
some traction to take those savings and
then to reinvest them into the next
round and so we have about fourteen
million dollars of things that we culled
from that list that the steam traps
being one example of that that we're
starting to you know tee up and get get
ready to do we put about a half a
million of administrative funds into
sort of seeding this operation we have
an alum who has promised us another half
a million and we're out and about trying
to find other people and there really
are a lot of people out there and
particularly among our alum who are
passionate about this so we're hoping to
get the funding together to keep this
project going so these are examples of
the kind of things we're doing and we're
going to focus a lot this year on the
research Enterprise on things like the
fume hoods where we really do have major
energy consumption and that is the
sub-sector of the overall behavioral
task force we have a task force that
just focuses on if people change
behaviors scientists and students
whatever what will make a difference so
we're going to focus on that this year
and we're going to focus very much as we
always do on measurement to really prove
to ourselves and to demonstrate how you
should in a discipline way and measure
what you're doing and be able to you
know aggregate that up into into
progress so that's a brief snapshot I
hope it will whet your appetite there's
never too many people working on this
across the Institute so we look forward
to working with all of you
why's that we've kept you longer than we
had intended and I apologize for that we
have lunch waiting for you outside and
as always we hate to sit between you and
lunch but I wonder if we might throw the
floor open just for a couple of
questions if there are maybe two short
questions and then we'll all join to the
to the area outside the auditorium and
the four of us will be available for
further questions then please we've got
music rather than the mic okay all right
my name is Jason Cohen and I question
for a president Hawk view and what was
right my question is about race and
diversity issue today at the end the
Institute and I know this one of the
slide that president Hockfield showed
was about diversity and there was a list
of different ongoing projects or
programs initiatives complete with a new
office of associate provost for
diversity I'm very delighted to see all
this happening but at the same time I
also wonder you know what concrete or
what specific steps have been our
Institute it's so far or what it's being
under being plan to improve race
relations and the Institute and I'm
asking this because as I realized some
of these programs actually probably have
already been around long enough for us
to be able to begin to see some new
results and outcomes and so on and one
example is for example the recall more
than a year ago in April of 2007 there
was a initiative on faculty raise issues
that was initiated by Provost office and
they were seen at a height accurate in
aftermath of a historic event at the
Institute that was our right after the
historic hunger strike by then professor
James Shirley in protest of
discrimination at the Institute
thereafter I recalled and the initiative
led to a preliminary report it was
published I thought in July 2007
with the number comments posted on the
web but ever since I don't recall I've
seen anything else after that and I
would like to ask the Provost what has
become of that initiative and some of
the other issues and and so on thank you
I'm just at where the maybe people want
to get lunch so we want to answer your
question question as efficiently as we
can say across the Institute we have put
increased focus on this and the major
result we can report is increased
numbers I would say among undergraduate
admissions the numbers haven't improved
dramatically since we started focusing
on this just recently and also among
graduate students there's been an
increase in the number of minority
graduate students Provost will answer
the issue from the faculty perspective
very briefly a couple of things first
first of all the initiative is alive and
well and working very hard there is a
group of faculty and staff and a couple
of postdocs working with them they have
assessed and assembled a gradient of
quantitative data they spent the bulk of
the summer interviewing a large number
of minority faculty to assess
qualitative information and they will
give a preliminary report to the faculty
meeting in a month or two so that that
activity is going well from the point of
view of activity and I expect to see a
report from them by the end of the
academic year in terms of more specific
issues beyond that the two associate
provost for faculty equity that
president Humphrey mentioned are working
very closely with the deans to assess
recruitment practices and to attract a
more diverse faculty to MIT so
everything we said in place is working
quite well and you're going to hear more
about it as progress becomes more
apparent thank you any other quick
questions before we move to lunch I
don't want to discourage you but I know
that many of you may be hungry let me
just offer the four of us will be
wandering around in the midst of lunch
and we encourage you to ask us questions
send us questions we think this is just
the opening of a conversation for the
year thank you very much for coming
you